when was the first time as a child you
can remember becoming aware of chemistry
the first time was when I was visiting
my uncle at his research laboratory at
his university and I was only I think
maybe 1011 and he's a physicist but what
he showed us was we went to his lab and
he poured out liquid nitrogen onto the
floor and for me that were it blew my
mind I was just how is this possible
he's generated this is like he was a
magician he'd conjured smoke out of thin
air pouring this dew of liquid nitrogen
spinning out across the floor you saw
this kind of smoke effect the kind of
things you'd see like on theater stages
that sort of thing and I just thought I
want to be able to play with that and
now I can
the first real hook I guess was at a
levels and as always there's a girl
involved there was an after-school Club
in chemistry and this girl I really
liked went along to this club so I
thought I better get interested in
chemistry too as it turned out the
chemistry was far more interesting than
the girl and it hooked me it really did
we're making catalysts at the time and
tiny palladium nanoparticles as well
which still some of the smallest ever
made
I think I was probably about seven years
old and my grant grant is a Welsh word
for grandfather yeah and when my grandma
a chemistry set for Christmas and we
played with the chemistry set on the
kitchen table and nan was really really
irritated but yeah that was the first
time I met chemistry but then chemistry
sort of disappeared until I got the
secondary school and had a really great
chemistry teacher a guy called M dave
Livesey and he really ignited my passion
for chemistry because he showed us
reactions in he and he showed us how
electrons moved in inside atoms and
around molecules and I suppose that was
that was the bit where the hawk was set
and that was when I really started to
get excited about chemistry
one Christmas I had I think it was the
junior encyclopedia of knowledge and and
in there there was the various
descriptions world flags and all of that
sort of thing as well but they were also
there's also two pages on on chemistry
and the two pictures that I remember
seeing in there were they they had this
kind of description about they had a
picture of like sodium and fire or
whatever you know what kind of you know
in water and the hydrogen coming off and
everything like that and they also had a
picture like a painted picture of a guy
with like a big suit on and with a
chlorine coming out of pipe and
basically the whole point was that that
the sodium is very reactive and chlorine
is very reactive very poisonous you put
them together you stick my table salt
and I think that was when I thought our
chemists are quite cool
probably when I started GCSEs at
secondary school so I was about 11 at
the time and Miss George was my teacher
and she taught me for I think all the
way through my GCSEs and she really
really got me into chemistry and then
that followed up in a levels - teachers
called Ian Nichols and Dennis black they
were fantastic really inspirational
teachers and they really got me into
chemistry
oh I don't know but I would guess I was
about ten and it was probably in science
class in primary school pretty much from
from the time I was certainly a young
teenager I wanted to be a chemist
I suppose when I was 9 or 10 when I was
reading science book that belonged to my
mother I've still got it here it's it's
a rather strange book it's an American
book that was written in 1903 and it's a
dialogue between big brother Jack and
various children called Tom and Agnes
and I've gotten the other names and he
gives them science lessons and they went
off to the druggie store and bought all
sorts of chemicals like gunpowder
sulfuric acid and did experiments and
that was the first time I'd heard of
chemistry to begin with I preferred
physics to chemistry but my maths wasn't
really good enough and when I was young
I had a very good memory so it made
chemistry particularly easy so I quite
quickly drifted to chemistry and I
really liked the color changes and the
smells in the lamp and so on
you